casas quemadas incendios forestales y
más de 1000 fallecidos y heridos es el
panorama que deja la ola de calor en
varios países europeos en grecia al
menos 10 helicópteros y nueve aviones
fueron necesarios para controlar las
conflagraciones en una zona montañosa en
la capital atenas cientos de personas
fueron evacuadas sin poder hacer nada
algunos vieron como sus viviendas y
coches eran consumidas por las llamas
en el norte de portugal la población
sufre voraces incendios con más de 2.000
bomberos intentando apagar los los
granjeros culpan al cambio climático de
destruir sus cultivos y matar a sus
animales temen que la situación empeore
en el futuro
no hay ningún lugar donde un animal
pueda beber no hay nada todavía tengo
olivos junto a un edificio con un pozo
pero nuestros nietos y la juventud en
general va a sufrir mucho si el cambio
climático no se detiene
mientras tanto en españa los 10 días de
intensas temperaturas dejan una alta
cifra de fallecidos y miles de hectáreas
de terreno calcinadas durante esta ola
de calor según los registros los datos
han sido más de 500 personas las que han
fallecido como consecuencia de las
temperaturas tan altas
además de todo lo que estamos viviendo
en términos de devastación como
consecuencia de los incendios parís
vivió su segundo día más caluroso desde
que se tiene registros en la capital con
40,5 grados centígrados pero menos de
los 40 y 2,6 grados centígrados que fue
su récord absoluto en julio de 2019
mientras que en gijón dos inmensos
incendios arrasaron más de 19 mil
hectáreas de bosque
italia reino unido y bélgica son otros
países europeos que también sufren las
consecuencias de calor científicos e
investigadores de la nasa y la oms
aseguran que el panorama climático
incluso podría ser peor en los próximos
días